i mean i'm sure you you read a lot of
scripts get off you know what was it
about this material that said oh i need
to be a part of this
well personally i've
the fact that
gary oldman was playing jackson lamb
for an actor it was a huge
huge thrill and also i just love
my character catherine standish i loved
reading about her and thinking wow you
know this
woman is
struggling and not very glamorous and
full of secrets and surprises and
that's great opportunity for me yeah
when you've got this
caliber of actors it's a you know
when you get offered when you get sent
the script and you see who's playing who
you're like oh it's got to be good you
know and then it is it is and it's so
it's so british as well and so messy
um and it's just the antithesis of a spy
thriller that we've come to to know
one of the things that i really enjoyed
is that both of your characters there's
a lot of stuff going on behind the
scenes and uh you know and that's what
makes a great spy show you know the fact
that there is so much subtext with these
characters yeah yeah yeah um
yeah they've all
all got secrets they're all living
double lives you know quite literally
because you know they can't
tell people what they do even though all
they do is a very unglamorized version
of an mi5 agent
and then within that with their
relationships with each other they're
not letting
you know people people know um
you know they're in a life
uh i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of shows and
movies so for soon to be fans of this
series is there anything that you think
they might like might be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show
well the
all the interior sets was on a lot it
was on a on a
studio but you'd never know especially
staring at the window i would stand on
that set sometimes and think girl that's
not real but
they've turned the lights on in
different ways and there's a car passing
and how did they do that
extraordinary magic
you know
set design and the production values
were incredible i thought
i i i actually when i was watching i um
i watch a lot of stuff i was convinced
it was a real place and it was only
reading the press notes that i realized
oh [ __ ] they built this and it's
incredible
yeah well then the first time we did a
walk on through the set we were all like
it's so meticulously detailed the
grottiness is so detailed that you do
come out of it feeling like a bit dirty
even though everything obviously is you
know brand new
i i read the books i loved reading the
books and i did feel like i was
i mean often books are lovely because
you you invent your own sets and your
own characters and your own
uh environment
uh you're free to do that
but i'm walking around [ __ ] slough house
i thought no this is exactly the way i
imagined it as i read it so um one of
the things i i think that gary is
jackson is so good um and
what's great about him is i think he
hates everybody but he still cares like
it's this great dynamic um
so do you think deep down he actually
cares or is he is it all a facade
you know what i mean
good question
i think he's very loyal and i think he
appreciates
everybody's
uh
abilities whether they're obvious or not
he can see
she's good at that he's good at that
he's actually good at that even though
he doesn't realize he is so i think
there's that but he has this
armadillo
yeah
suits
he's got a problem about saying anything
nice to anybody
oh i did notice that
um so normally i don't get to say this
but as a fan of the first six episodes
you know at the end there's a trailer
for
what's coming so um i uh what can you
tease
in the second half
some secrets get revealed
yeah yeah very good
and some more
hatched i think
yeah secrets revealed in secrets yeah
i like that so when you guys signed on
did you know obviously you knew it was
uh the the 12 episodes did you have all
the scripts at once or was it like a
script by script thing as you were going
we had all the first six i think yeah
yeah no i'm not really i can't remember
actually
yeah the first six
that's the first six initially yeah
was it uh one of these things where
because sometimes on shows there's like
the rainbow pages where things keep
changing along the way but this feels
very much like it was
like one vision was it one of those kind
of things where it kind of stuck to the
script
yeah those rainbow pages as you call
them often aren't
they don't change direction they just
improve
what's there and i think as you
start to film as you start to get really
stuck into how things work
better options become available
and in terms of just keeping everybody
up to speed
the pages have to change color i mean
sometimes when they change
like the whole spectrum of the rainbow
you say oh they're changing their mind a
bit too much perhaps that indicates an
insecurity but not in this situation at
all no
and also they were very open the writers
the producers and the director very open
to collaboration
so if one of us came up with a really
good idea they would have to change it
yeah that's great we'll do that yeah oh
we have to send notes to everyone so
that would get winged around and another
color would come in
but that that was more of this that was
more of a sign of everybody working
together than it falling apart yeah yeah
in this case
on that note i need to wrap up i really
want to say sincere congratulations and
thank you for talking with me this
morning thank you cheers